This is the brief on the
disastrous dinner party at
Castle Ravenloft.
In this Wild three session arc,
a group of adventurers accepts a
dinner invitation from the
vampire Lord Strad, hoping to
reunite their ally Izmark with
his missing sister.
But the evening quickly
collapses into absolute
bloodshed.
First, this diplomatic dinner
turns into an emotional
nightmare.
You see, Strad plays the
gracious host, even granting
Izmark's request to see his
sister Irena, but the heroes are
completely crushed to discover
she's already been turned into a
vampire.
Even worse, she's wearing the
Amulet of Ravenkind, a lost
artifact they desperately need
to defeat Strad, literally
taunting the group with their
past failures.
Second, the castle claims a
leader's life after Strad
suddenly vanishes.
The group explores the keep, but
their curiosity turns fatal.
Out on the parapets, they fight
a suit of animated armor and
their attacks literally just
bounce right off the steel.
The construct brutally slays
Izmark, their primary ally and
village leader, leaving our
survivors totally leaderless in
enemy territory.
Finally, the retreat becomes a
full on panic.
They trigger crazy traps of
poison gas and giant spiders
splitting up in the chaos.
One hero gets cornered by a
literal blood monster, while
another accidentally summons an
invisible, enraged apparition of
Strad just by disturbing an
ancient wedding cake.
Yeah, it forces a totally
terrified route.
As you can see, what started as
a rescue mission resulted in
their target becoming an undead
enemy, the death of a key ally,
and a desperate scramble to
escape alive.
They definitely learned the hard
way that in Barovia, dinner with
the devil.
Today we are, we're doing
something a little different,
and honestly, it's a little
terrifying.
We're stepping right into the
lion's den.
Or, well, I guess more
accurately, the vampire's dining
room.
Right.
Yeah.
It's a classic trope for a very
good reason.
You know, the the polite
invitation to dinner issued by
the villain?
Yeah.
It's this moment where the
physical conflict just pauses,
right?
And the psychological warfare
really begins.
It's it's Hannibal Lecter
serving wine.
It's Darth Vader sitting at the
head of the table in Cloud City.
Oh man, that is such a good
comparison.
It's exactly that.
It's that moment where you
absolutely know you are
outmatched, but you kind of have
to pretend you're just having a
nice normal meal.
Precisely.
It's a suspension of the rules
of war, but really only on a
superficial level, because
underneath the surface the war
is actually intensifying.
It just it shifts from swords
and spells to words and
perceptions.
Exactly.
And so for you listening, we are
looking at a stack of logs
today.
This is data from sessions 2728
and 29.
It involves a party of
adventurers, your horn, Bradley
and Pearlan, and their ally is
Mark.
And the premise here is actually
pretty simple.
They have finally accepted an
invitation to dine at Castle
Ravenloft with Strad
Vonzarevich.
But as we're going to see as we
dig into this, the dinner is
really merely a pretext.
The true purpose of this visit,
at least from Straud's
perspective, seems to be a
systematic, almost clinical
dismantling of the party's hope.
Yeah, it's brutal.
We have three sessions of really
dense material here.
We're covering everything from a
very tactical ambush on the
road, to the horrific reveal of
a lost ally, to the literal
burning of the castle itself.
It is a totally chaotic ride.
We've got deception, we've got
the corruption of innocence, and
we definitely have some serious
tactical blunders.
So our mission for this deep
dive is to analyze exactly,
exactly how Stroud uses his
environment, how he uses his
so-called hospitality to break
his enemies before he even has
to lift a single finger to fight
them.
Right.
And we also really need to look
at the tragic arc of is Mark
here the burgomaster?
His story in these three
sessions is.
Devastating.
It really is.
It's devastating highlights the
actual cost of heroism in a
setting where the deck is just
completely rigged against you.
Truly.
OK, so let's unpack this.
We start right in session 27.
The party is leaving the Wizards
of Wine and they are heading
straight to the castle.
They are highly motivated is
Mark especially is very eager.
They really think they're going
on a rescue mission to save is
Mark's sister Irina.
Right.
And immediately, right off the
bat, the tone is set by the
environment.
They are on the swalage road and
they get hit by an ambush.
But the thing you have to
understand is this isn't just a
random encounter, it is highly
tactical.
Yeah, looking at the logs here,
an armored figure rides out on a
skeletal horse, shoots a bunch
of arrows.
And then, and this is the part
that is just so annoying as a
player rides right back into the
trees.
It's shooting scoop tactics.
Yeah, it's classic guerrilla
warfare, but employed by the
undead.
These enemies are revenants.
Now, just to be clear, revenants
are not your standard shambling,
mindless zombies.
They are highly intelligent,
incredibly vengeful spirits that
have possessed a corpse.
Their entire existence is fueled
by a very specific hatred or a
singular goal.
What makes them so dangerous?
Exactly, and by using this
mobile archery, riding out,
firing and retreating, they are
actively baiting the party.
They want the party get
frustrated and break formation.
And it totally works.
The party chases the horseman
because they think they can
corner him in the woods, but
while they are distracted by
that, an ogre zombie just
lumbers out from the woods
behind them to cut off their
escape route.
It is a textbook pincer
movement.
It's the hammer and anvil
maneuver.
The ogre is your anvil, it's a
big, slow, incredibly hard
hitting obstacle that just pins
you in place, and the revenants
on the horses are the hammer
striking repeatedly from the
flanks.
It shows you that Strauds forces
aren't just some mindless mob,
they are an army with real
tactical acumen.
And this tactic nearly works
perfectly.
Yeah, his mark, who let's
remember, is a skilled fighter,
but it's very much still mortal.
He just gets hammered here.
The log says.
He takes these massive crushing
blows from the ogre and then the
horseman reapers from the trees
and puts 2 arrows right into him
and it goes down.
This is such a key foreshadowing
moment for the rest of the deep
dive.
Ismark is essentially the moral
center of this group right now.
He is the one with the deep
personal stake in this.
Yeah, it's his sister.
Right.
And here, right at the literal
gates of his enemy's land, he is
almost killed.
It establishes the stakes for
you immediately.
Ismark is fragile.
The party isn't just fighting
for their own survival.
They're escorting Avip, who is
very, very mortal.
It creates this underlying
secondary objective in every
single combat encounter they
face.
You have to protect the
Burgomaster.
Which just skyrockets the
tension.
I mean, it's only Eurohorn's
really quick thinking riding his
Mountain Lion companion over and
casting Cure Wounds that saves
is Mark's life in that mud.
Let's actually pause on that
image for just a second.
A Ranger mounted on a Mountain
Lion, weaving through a chaotic
combat zone to deliver magical
medical aid.
That is high fantasy heroism at
its absolute peak.
But I want you to notice the
contrast here.
It's high fantasy heroism
meeting really gritty tactical
horror.
Speaking of gritty horror, there
is a super creepy detail in the
logs here that I really do not
want to gloss over.
When they finally managed to
kill the revenants, the things
actually laugh at them.
They laughed and say, we shall
meet again.
Because they absolutely will.
Like I said, Revenants are
vengel spirits that possessed
corpses.
If you destroy the physical body
they are currently wearing, the
spirit itself isn't destroyed,
it just floats right off into
the woods and finds another
corpse to inhabit.
It is a relentless cycle.
And the really messed up part is
the party realizes these
revenants are actually
inhabiting the bodies of other
adventurers who were recently
slain in this land.
It implies this massive history
of failure.
The party realizes they aren't
the first group to try this.
Dozens, maybe hundreds of heroes
have come before them and now
their actual physical bodies are
being used as weapons against
the new heroes.
That is deep psychological
warfare.
You are literally fighting your
predecessors.
That is just so grim.
It's like the land itself is
just recycling its victims.
It is exactly that, and I want
you to look at what Radley does
in the aftermath of this fight.
He literally strips the
chainmail right off one of the
dead bodies.
He takes a great sword, a
healing potion and even a scroll
of revivification.
It really highlights the sheer
scarcity in Borovia.
If you want to survive, you have
to scavenge from the people who
failed before you.
Radley is quite literally
wearing a dead man's armor to a
dinner party.
It's a waste not want not kind
of situation, but taken to the
most macabre extreme imaginable.
Like, just try to imagine
showing up to a fancy dinner
party wearing the shirt of the
guy who just died in the host's
driveway.
It sends a message whether he
intended it to or not.
It says to Strad we will do
whatever it takes to survive.
But at the same time, it also
marks them as scavengers.
They are barely scraping by.
Right, so they survived as
brutal ambush.
They skirt past the town of
Valaki and finally reach the
gates of Ravenloft.
And this is exactly where the
atmospheric horror kicks into
high gear.
The weather turns incredibly
violent immediately.
We are talking massive Thunder,
lightning strikes and there is a
coach just waiting for them.
An unmanned coach, importantly.
Which is always, always a giant
red flag.
The doors of the coach just open
automatically.
There's no driver, just two
dark, terrifying horses.
It's Stride basically
broadcasting.
I control everything here.
I don't even need living
servants to fetch you.
Exactly.
It also totally removes the
ability for the party to
interact with the human element
before arriving.
Usually in this kind of scenario
you chat with the driver on the
way up, right?
Maybe get some gossip, some
Intel on the castle layout.
Bribe him a little.
Yeah, exactly.
But here there is just silence,
just the mechanics of the trap
slowly closing around them.
They're being transported like
pieces of cargo.
And the journey itself is
designed specifically to make
them feel tiny.
They have to cross this massive
drawbridge over a huge gorge,
the source material notes.
It's a 50 foot wide gorge with
sheer walls that are 100 feet
high.
It's an imposing physical
barrier.
And the bridge is loudly
creaking and swaying violently
in the storm winds.
It's so precarious.
It really feels like you are
crossing a threshold into a
world where the normal laws of
safety just completely cease to
apply.
That's spot on.
In classical literature,
crossing a bridge very often
symbolizes a transition from the
world of the living into the
underworld.
Think of the River Styx.
Once they cross that swaying,
rotting wood over that drop,
they have fully left the safety
of the known world behind them.
They are undeniably in Strad's
domain now.
And the moment they cross that
bridge, they meet the welcoming
committee Rahedin the
Chamberlain.
Rahedin is a fascinating figure.
He is a dusk elf.
Now, without getting too bogged
down into the deep lore, you
should know the dusk elves have
a horrific, tragic history with
Strad that involves absolute
genocide, and Rahedin actually
betrayed his own people to serve
Strad.
He is a traitor to his entire
race, but he is unflinchingly
only loyal to his master.
Wow, and the source specifically
knows he has this terrifying
aura.
As he gets physically closer to
the adventurers, they start
hearing screaming voices in
their heads.
It is a literal auditory psychic
assault.
The screams get louder and more
desperate the closer he gets to
you.
It's strongly implies a personal
history of violence that is so
profound it literally clings to
his being.
These are very likely the souls
of the thousands of people he
has personally killed or
betrayed.
He is a walking war crime.
And notice the stark contrast
test here.
The party is visibly revulsed.
They are clutching their ears in
pain and rotting is just
completely emotionless.
He offers this incredibly terse,
polite welcome.
It is just mundane bureaucracy
wrapped up in eternal torment.
He normalizes the horror.
To him, the screaming of the
damned is just background noise.
He politely asks for their coats
while the souls of his victims
are shrieking into their ears.
It completely disarms the party.
Because really, how do you
politely respond to that kind of
greeting?
You can't.
He leads them into the Great
Hall, which has the classic
cobwebs, huge vaulted ceilings,
very gothic vibes, and then he
opens these massive bronze doors
to the banquet hall and suddenly
we are just in a completely
different movie.
Yes, the sensory shift here is
incredibly jarring.
Outside it is Thunder, lightning
and swaying bridges over death
drops.
Inside it is bright crystal
chandeliers, tables laden with
roasted beast, amber liquid
sitting in fine goblets.
It is pure opulence.
It's civilization.
And there's music playing.
A massive pipe organ.
Yeah.
And who is sitting there playing
it?
The man himself, Strad von
Zarevich.
Playing and raptured ecstasy, as
the log specifically notes, and
this is key, it is a
performance.
He desperately wants them to see
him not just as a brutal
warlord, but as an artist, as a
sophisticate.
He is capable of creating
beauty.
It immediately complicates their
view of him.
If he was just a snarling
monster, it would be very easy
to hate him and fight him.
But a monster who plays
beautiful box style fugues?
That is deeply unsettling.
Right, so he finishes, stops
playing, turns around and plays
the gracious host.
And I have to say, this
conversation at the dinner table
is a complete minefield.
Strad is just so deeply
arrogant.
He casually apologizes for not
eating the food with them
because it's quote no longer his
custom, which you know, is a
polite way of saying he drinks
human blood.
It's a massive power move.
He is saying I am providing for
you, but I am entirely above
your petty biological needs.
And then he just starts
monologuing about his past
conquests.
He wants them to fully
understand that he earned his
land through blood and war.
He frames himself as a noble
conqueror, a bringer of order,
rather than a bloodthirsty
tyrant.
But then we get to the actual
mistakes made by the party.
Radley.
Oh, Radley Stride is just
chatting them up, making
conversation, and Radley decides
it's a great time to mention
that the party is staying with
the Mardikov family at the
Wizards of Wine.
This is a critical intelligence
failure.
It is a massive breach of
operational security.
Right.
Why on earth would he volunteer
that information?
It is highly likely a mix of
severe nerves and a misplaced
sense of social reciprocity.
This is a very common
psychological phenomenon,
actually.
When someone who is in a
position of extreme power treats
you politely, you feel a deep,
almost involuntary social urge
to be polite right back.
Straud asks a casual question,
and Radley answers it simply
because it would feel socially
rude not to.
But the consequences of that are
huge.
The Mardakovs are the resistance
network.
They run the winery, which
supplies literally the only joy
left in Barovia.
Exactly.
Radley just casually handed the
location of the primary
resistance cell directly to the
head of the secret police.
The expert commentary in the
notes points out that Stroud
regards him curiously after
this.
He's probably sitting there
thinking.
I cannot believe it was actually
that easy.
He didn't even have to torture
anyone or cast a spell.
He just passed the bread rolls
and asked.
So where are you folks staying
these days?
Meanwhile, You're a Horn is
making a totally different
approach.
He's actively trying to provoke
Stroud by feeding pieces of meat
to his Mountain Lion right at
the dinner table.
Which is certainly a bold move.
It's a deliberate, calculated
breach of etiquette.
He's trying to non verbally say
I do not respect your rules or
your authority, but Straw just
ignores it completely.
He is too ancient, too
completely secure in his power
to be baited by bad table
manners from Immortal.
He treats it exactly like a
parent ignoring a toddler
throwing food on the floor.
It just reinforces his absolute
superiority in the room.
But then the trap finally snaps
shut.
You're a Horn decides to ask the
big question, he says.
Can we see Irena?
And this is the pivotal moment.
Straw just laughs.
He's like, sure, let me get her
for you.
This is the moment Ismark has
been waiting for his entire
life.
It seems he's fully ready to
rescue his sister right now.
Rashi opens the bronze doors and
in walks Irina.
But something is deeply wrong.
Yes.
Everything is wrong.
She is dressed in this dark
black evening gown.
Her skin is completely alabaster
and her eyes are red.
She has been turned.
She's a full vampire.
And it is not just her.
She is actually accompanied into
the room by Yeska.
This is the missing altar boy
from the church in Valaki.
He's wearing this dirty cassock,
but he has a frilled collar over
it, which is a horrible mockery
of his priesthood.
And he's a vampire now, too.
This is a crushing reveal of the
logs.
It is not a combat encounter.
It is the actual presentation of
their ultimate failure.
And the real kicker here, the
detail that makes it so much
worse.
Irena is wearing the Amulet of
Ravenkind.
That is the dagger right in the
heart.
For those who don't know, the
amulet is this incredibly
powerful holy artifact that the
party spent multiple past
sessions desperately trying to
find.
It actively radiates sunlight.
It is the ultimate weapon
against vampires in this world,
and they lost it when their
cleric died in a previous
session.
And now it is literally hanging
around the neck of the very
vampire they came here to
destroy, worn proudly by the
woman they came here to save.
It is a total devastating
inversion of their entire quest.
It is Strad loudly saying your
greatest tools of salvation are
now just my casual jewelry.
It actively mocks their efforts.
It renders their entire campaign
up to this exact point a
complete and utter failure.
Ismark's reaction in the logs is
just heartbreaking to read.
He yells outcalls Strad, a
monster.
He instinctively reaches for his
sword to fight and Strad.
He's doesn't even bother to draw
a weapon or cast a spell.
He just laughs at him and
vanishes.
Because he leaves them alone
with their failure, he
fundamentally doesn't need to
fight them.
He has already won this
engagement entirely on his
terms.
He took their main mission
objective which was save Irena,
and turned it into a horrific
new reality where she is now an
active enemy.
And by vanishing like that he
completely denies them the
catharsis of combat.
If they could just fight him
right there, they could feel
like they were actively doing
something.
But he leaves them all alone
with his victim.
And Arena.
She isn't the sweet, scared girl
Radley remembers in the village.
She's cruel.
Now she purposely walks over and
sits right in Straud's empty
chair.
She casually taunts them.
She dodges all their frantic
questions about the layout of
the castle.
And Yeska, this little innocent
altar boy just hisses at them
with what the log calls a
murderous visage.
It is the ultimate corruption of
innocence.
Straud has taken the exact
things the party cares about,
family, religion, childhood,
innocence and worked them into
weapons.
This is the very definition of
gothic horror.
It isn't just about cheap jump
scares or gore.
It's about the systemic
degradation of the good in the
world.
And then, exactly like Straw
did, Arena just casually
dissolves into mist and leaves
the room.
Leaving the party completely
alone in this massive banquet
hall.
The dinner is officially over.
The host has left.
Their status as guests has been
fully revoked.
Now they are just intruders in a
very dangerous house.
So there they are.
They are just standing there
alone in this huge room.
There's all this uneaten food on
the table is Mark is completely
devastated, probably in shock,
and they collectively realize,
OK, well, we are inside the
castle.
The bad guys just left.
What do we do now?
And this naturally begins
segment 3 of the logs, The
architecture of madness.
They make the choice to explore,
but I want you to notice the
massive shift in tone here.
The castle essentially changes
around them.
It goes from being an opulent
palace to a terrifying dungeon.
Yeah, they walk out of the
dining room into the hallway,
and suddenly they're just
vampire spawn clinging to the
walls, crawling around, just
leering down at them, But they
don't attack.
Which is a massive show of
restraint and power.
Strad is communicating you are
currently alive solely because I
am allowing it.
It creates this immense
suffocating tension.
They're basically walking
through a sharp tank and all the
sharks are just watching them
with hungry eyes.
Every single step they take is a
severe test of their nerve.
So they head down to the Hall of
Faith.
It's this ruined Chapel area,
and there's a corpse on the
floor clutching a holy icon, and
there's a single mysterious ray
of light shining down on it.
This is a great example of
environmental storytelling.
The corpse alone implies a whole
tragic story.
Someone clearly tried to find
sanctuary in this holy place and
failed miserably.
Radley and your horn immediately
go to loot the body, which
brings that scavenging theme
right back to the forefront.
They take a black Mace and a
cloak off the guy, but they
specifically choose to leave the
icon.
Why do you think they left it?
I mean, it's a holy item in a
vampire castle.
Extreme paranoia in a place that
is this deeply cursed.
Seeing a perfect ray of light
shining down on a holy object
just looks entirely too good to
be true.
They instantly suspect it's a
trap.
Strad has successfully at this
point made them absolutely
afraid of hope itself.
Which really shows exactly how
paranoid they've become in just
a few hours.
Then they decide to go upstairs
and they meet.
Honestly my favorite weirdo in
this entire dungeon.
Leaf lip siege.
Yes, the accountant.
He's literally chained to a
desk.
He's sitting there doing straws
taxes.
It is the banality of evil I
mentioned earlier.
Amidst all the gothic horror and
the blood drinking, someone
still has to sit down and
balance the books.
Castles require heavy
maintenance, armies require
regular payment.
Leaf completely ignores these
heavily armed intruders to just
focus on Straws finances.
It is just so absurd.
They walk in like, excuse me, we
are here to violently kill the
master of this castle.
And he's just like, yes, yes,
take him.
Remember, I'm currently
calculating the annual grain
tide from the village.
It beautifully grounds the
horror in this strange, almost
administrative reality.
Leaf isn't a terrifying monster
in the traditional sense.
He is a pencil pushing
functionary.
He represents the boring
bureaucracy of this terrible
occupation, and the fact that he
is physically chained to his
desk tells you everything you
could ever need to know about
Straud's employment benefits
package.
Right.
And he just sneers at them.
He tells them I'm busy and the
art is so thrown off they just
leave and be.
They move on and find the throne
room.
And here is a tiny detail that
the source material specifically
flags as bizarre.
The throne in the room faces the
wall.
Yes, it faces South, pointing
completely away from the room
itself.
Why?
What is your actual take on that
architectural choice?
It is purely symbolic, I
believe.
A ruler typically sits facing
his court.
He faces the people he rules
over.
By having the throne face the
blank wall, Straud is physically
turning his back on his subjects
on the living world entirely.
It strongly suggests he has
absolutely no interest in
actually ruling this land.
He is only interested in his own
dark obsessions.
Or perhaps he's staring at
something that only he can see,
like the ghosts of his past.
Either way, it heavily
emphasizes his utter isolation.
It's super unnerving to just
walk into a room and see that.
So they keep going up.
They eventually hit the rooftop.
It is absolutely pouring rain
outside, and then the storm
clouds physically form into
Strad's giant face and just
start spewing swarms of bats at
them.
It's a massive demonstration of
Dominion.
He is telling them he is the
land itself.
He literally controls the
weather patterns.
Now, mechanically, the bats are
mostly just a nuisance, but the
message is incredibly powerful.
There is nowhere outside these
walls where you are safe.
It effectively forces them right
back inside.
It traps them within the
terrifying architecture of the
castle.
Yeah, they retreat right back
inside the door and immediately
run into a ghost.
That wait for it turns out to
just be a scary mannequin on
strings.
They literal prank.
A prank.
The ancient vampire Lord is
trolling them in his own house.
It highlights his very juvenile
sense of humor, or perhaps just
his deep, eternal boredom.
He is actively toying with them.
He wants to hear them scream in
terror and then immediately feel
incredibly foolish for screaming
at a doll.
It deconstructs their sense of
heroism.
It makes them feel like silly
children wandering through a
cheap haunted house attraction
instead of epic heroes.
They do actually find a real
fight eventually.
There's this zombie ambush out
on the King's balcony, but the
source notes it's a very simple
combat encounter.
They just cut the zombies down
easily.
It's almost too easy for them.
Because the physical threat
isn't the real point of this
place yet the castle is designed
to wear them down mentally 1st.
And now we move right into
segment 4 of the logs where they
start meeting the other
residents of these upper floors.
This is where that uncomfortable
social horror returns in full
force.
Right.
You're searching around and they
find a secret door, which, good
job by Pearland spotting that.
And behind it they find a
bedroom and there's a young girl
hiding in there, Helga Ruvak.
She claims she's just a maid
from the village, a simple boot
maker's daughter.
And here is where we see the
absolute tragedy of the
community breakdown in Borovia
is Mark, who is the Burgo
master.
The leader of that village
doesn't know who she is.
He looks at her, says the
villagers are very reclusive and
just shrugs.
That is wild to me.
The elected leader of this tiny
village doesn't even know his
own people by sight.
It shows you exactly how
fractured the society really is
under Stroud's rule.
Pure fear keeps everyone
completely isolated in their
homes.
Neighbors don't know their
neighbors, because trusting
anyone gets you killed or taken.
So Helga begs them.
She pleads to be taken with
them, but the party, they just
leave her.
They leave her behind.
They promise her they'll come
back later, but the log says she
looks desperate and forlorn as
they shut the door.
They've become so wildly
suspicious of everything in this
castle that they can't even
trust a crying girl.
And honestly, from a survival
standpoint, they're completely
right to be suspicious.
In Ravenloft, innocence is very
often just a mask for a trap,
but making that choice still
deeply erodes the morality.
They are being forced to make
these very cold, calculated
equations.
Is she a trap?
Even if she isn't, can we
actually afford to escort a
defenseless civilian through a
vampire lair right now?
And they decided the answer was
no.
They're becoming colder, just
like the stone of the castle.
Then they keep moving and find
Gertruda, and this is honestly
even sadder.
She's the teenage daughter of a
woman known as Mad Mary from the
village.
The party has actually been
hearing rumors about her missing
daughter for several sessions,
and they find her in this
incredibly lavish, fancy bedroom
that smells heavily of expensive
perfume.
And she's completely, totally
delusional.
She actually thinks Straud is
this charming, wonderful Prince.
She truly believes she's living
in a beautiful fairy tale.
She's entirely oblivious to the
lethal danger she's in.
She even casually mentions to
the party that her personal
attendant has quote body parts
of different animals, which is
just so serving.
She is describing the mongrel
folk, but Gertrude doesn't see
the horror of these stitched
together creatures.
She sees magic.
She actively interprets the
grotesque reality of the castle
as whimsical and fun.
It shows you the incredible
tragic power of human denial
when faced with absolute trauma.
The party desperately tries to
warn her.
They try to explain what Stride
is, but she just speaks so
adoringly of him and is Mark, to
his absolute credit as a leader,
refuses to just leave her alone
in there.
He decides to stay behind in the
room to protect her while the
rest of the party continues
exploring the floor.
Good guy is Mark.
I mean, even after just seeing
his own sister turned into a
monster, he's still desperately
trying to save this random girl
he is cleaning so hard to his
duty as the Burgo master.
But the rest of the party moves
on and enters a study.
And this is exactly where the
timeline of the whole story gets
incredibly wonky.
They look up and find a portrait
hanging right over the mantle.
The paint is clearly centuries
old, but the subject of the
painting is Irina.
The painting looks exactly
identically like is Mark's
sister, but it is dated from
hundreds of years ago.
This is the massive hammer drop
for is Mark.
He comes in and he sees his
beloved sister, who is currently
in her 20s, depicted perfectly
in a painting from the distant
ancient past.
How's that even possible in the
lore?
It firmly points to the cycle.
The curse of Strad is
fundamentally cyclical.
Tatiana, who was Strad's
original human love centuries
ago, is constantly reincarnated
over and over again.
Strad has been hunting and
chasing this poor woman's soul
across generations.
Irena is just the current
physical vessel.
She isn't just a random victim.
She is a rerun of an ancient
tragedy.
And is Mark just breaks when he
realizes this, the log says.
He literally lapses into sobs.
It's just entirely too much for
one person.
Person.
His sister's a vampire, and now
he finds out she might just be a
tiny part of some ancient,
inescapable curse loop.
He collapses on the floor.
He realizes in that moment that
his entire family's personal
tragedy is really just a minor
blip in Strad's eternal,
horrific soap opera.
It completely minimizes his
personal pain.
And while he's sitting there
weeping on the floor, the party
actually starts arguing with
each other as Mark turns and
blames Radley, yelling.
I specifically asked you to take
her to safety and Radley yells
back.
I took her to Valaki exactly
like I promised I would.
It's all falling apart right
there.
The team cohesion is completely
shattering.
Extreme stress just brings out
all the cracks in a group and
this perfectly leads us into
session 29 and Segment 5 of the
outline The Fatal Mistakes.
Because right as they are
arguing, raw greed starts to
creep into their decision
making.
Yes.
They discover a secret room
hidden behind the fireplace in
the study.
Inside, it's very stark.
There is just a single corpse
holding a torch and a large
chest full of gold sitting
there.
That is the most classic trap
set up in D&D history.
A corpse and a treasure chest in
a hidden room.
It practically screams Do not
touch this.
And Yurihorn knows it.
He specifically tells everyone
to back out and leave the room.
He's very suspicious.
He verbally identifies it as a
trap, but then he.
Opens it anyway.
His curiosity just gets the
absolute better of him.
He opens the lid of the chest.
And woosh, a massive cloud of
green gas fills the room.
He instantly hits the floor,
completely unconscious.
Radley rushes into the room to
try and pull him out, and he
inhales the gas and hits the
floor too.
Both of the party's heavy,
physical hitters are out cold in
an instant.
So now it is entirely up to
Pearland the monk.
He manages to hold his breath,
runs in and drags your horn out
into the hallway.
But he can't manage to get
Radley, the gas is just too
thick and heavy, so he props
your horn up in a chair to
recover.
This is a very specific moment
in the logs that I really want
to highlight for you.
You're a horn.
The Ranger has a Mountain Lion
companion.
His beast companion.
Yes, but right now Yuri Horn is
totally unconscious, so the
magically bonded Mountain Lion
is currently just a regular
hungry Mountain Lion.
The magical bond of control is
temporarily severed, so Purlane
is suddenly just scaring down a
massive feral predator in a
small room.
The source text describes this
incredibly tense moment where
the large cat jumps up onto the
table, turns and coldly regards
the monk, and Pearland realizes
with terror, This wild animal
will not obey my commands.
He has to back away very, very
slowly.
It's such a small passing detail
in the session, but it adds so
much incredible tension.
Your best friend's trusted pet
instantly becomes a lethal
threat the exact moment your
friend goes down.
It brilliantly reinforces how
incredibly fragile their control
over this entire situation
really is.
And eventually, while they are
waiting around recovering from
the gas, they get bored and
decide to explore yet another
secret passage.
They found the spider bell free.
Oh man, this is an absolute
disaster from start to finish.
They walk in and find a rope
hanging down from a bell and
they pull it.
Why do adventurers always feel
the need to pull the random
rope?
It's what I call the big red
button syndrome.
If you put a lever in a room,
players will pull it.
If there is a dangling rope,
they will yank it.
They just can't help themselves.
Well, in Castle Raven, locked
pulling the rope just rings a
giant dinner bell for the local
giant spiders.
Six of them drop right down from
the ceiling on top of them.
Now they do fight them off.
The party is actually very good
at tactical combat.
They can easily handle a few
spiders, but the webs these
spiders drop are incredibly
thick and sticky.
So you're a horn who has
recovered by now has a bright
idea.
He says.
Let's just use fire to bring the
webs away.
Right, let's start a fire in a
wooden belfry in an incredibly
ancient, dry castle full of old
timber.
It works entirely too well.
The webs ignite instantly, the
dry wooden Timbers catch fire,
and suddenly the actual roof of
Castle Raven Loft is on fire.
This is a huge turning point for
the group.
They've officially gone from
being stealthy, careful
explorers to accidental
arsonists.
And from a tactical perspective,
it is a complete disaster.
You now have fixed smoke,
extreme heat and severe
structural instability to deal
with.
The castle is quite literally
burning down right around them.
The level of chaos is escalating
rapidly.
They have to flee the area
immediately, which pushes them
blindly and panicked right into
the next encounter.
And it is amidst all this fire
and smoke and chaos that we get
the ultimate tragedy of these
sessions, Segment 6, the death
of his mark.
This is a frantic sequence of
events that plays out exactly
like the finale of a slasher
movie.
Perlin is desperately exploring
the outside parapets by climbing
through a wardrobe window to
escape the smoke, and out there
he finds a hulking suit of red
armor just standing on the
balcony.
And it's not just decorative
armor, it's magically animated
armor, and it immediately starts
chasing him.
Perlon is a monk, so he's very
fast.
He sprints right back inside,
through the window into the
bedroom where Ismark and
Gertruda are still hiding, but
this massive suit of armor just
stomps right in after.
Him.
So now is Mark, who is already
just completely emotionally
wrecked from crying over the
painting, has to stand up and
fight.
He draws his long sword.
Gertrude is cowering in the
corner, screaming her head off.
Pearland is frantically punching
this solid metal thing.
And the armor is completely
relentless.
It is heavily resistant to
standard physical damage.
Worse, it uses area of effect
lightning attacks.
The source logs specifically say
that is.
Mark's sword just clangs
harmlessly off the plating, and
Pearland manages to dent it a
bit, but the construct shows
absolutely no sign of fatigue.
It is an unfeeling machine of
death.
And then it finally happens.
The armor swiftly bypasses is
Mark's guard and it just slays
him.
The log is incredibly blunt
about it is Mark the Brigomaster
is slain, but the physical
imagery the DM uses is so
specific and so cruel he
physically falls backward and he
dies with his dead eyes staring
directly through the open door
toward the study with his
sister's ancient portrait.
God, that is just devastating.
He died looking right at the
eternal evidence of his sister's
inescapable curse.
He entirely failed to save her
from Stride, he completely
failed to save himself, and he
died in his enemies fancy guest
bedroom fighting a random piece
of animated furniture.
It completely severs the party's
emotional anchor to Borovia.
Ismark was their true moral
compass.
He was the literal reason they
were on this quest to begin
with.
With him dead on the floor, the
whole mission loses its heart.
They are no longer brave heroes
helping a desperate brother, say
his family.
They are now just desperate
intruders trapped in a burning
house, trying to survive the
night.
And Pearland actually goes down
to the armor, just trucks right
over him right after it kills is
Mark.
Yeah, and when they finally wake
up later, are they captured in
the bench and they've just been
moved?
They wake up resting in a
different comfortable guest
room.
Is Mark's dead body is
completely gone, the Mountain
Lion is gone, and there is just
some guy lounging on a velvet
couch nearby Escher.
Oh, this guy, he's just so
painfully casual about the whole
thing.
He's like, oh, hello there, I
saw you boys got dragged in here
unconscious.
Escher is a vampire spawn, but
he's a very unique one in the
castle's hierarchy.
He is a consort, he has this
handsome, faded elegance about
him, and he is entirely,
completely self obsessed.
He doesn't care about the party
or their dead friend at all.
He just casually complaints
about how Strawd used to find
him beautiful but is now growing
bored of him.
He tells them he's terrified of
being quote locked away in a
crypt.
It gives the players this really
dark glimpse into the inevitable
future of Strad's toys.
You get played with until he's
bored and then you just get put
away at a box forever.
It perfectly illustrates the
cold dispensability of Strad's
affections.
Escher is essentially just a
discarded sad pet now.
The party briefly considers
killing him right there.
Your horn actually whispers to
the others.
Should we take him out?
But they are so badly battered
at this point, Radley and
Pearline just shake their heads
and decide no unnecessary
confrontation right now.
So they literally just turn and
walk aware and Esher just goes
right back to reading his book
on the couch.
The absolute disrespect of it
all.
But to be fair, they do have
much bigger problems to deal
with.
They walk back into the study
where the painting is and they
notice the fire in the hearth
has been neatly relit.
Your truth is completely gone.
His Marks body is gone and his
blood has been mostly cleaned
off the floor, but a faint dark
stain remains on the rug.
It is exactly like the castle is
quietly resetting itself.
It's scrubbing away any impact
they had, The huge fire they
started in the belfry?
It's likely been magically
extinguished or safely contained
by servants, the bodies of their
friends quietly removed.
It's a tactic to make their
violent struggle feel completely
meaningless.
The House always wins.
So they keep moving and Yuri
Horn decides to investigate a
dark bathing chamber they find.
He looks inside and sees a large
bathtub completely full of this
thick, dark liquid.
Rule #1 of horror.
Never ever look in the creepy
tub.
Exactly.
A screaming, horrifying figure
made entirely of blood just
erupts out of the tub.
It leaps up and clings to the
ceiling.
This is very likely a
specialized vampire spawn, or
perhaps one of the brides using
some advanced form of blood
magic.
It drips and splashes thick
blood everywhere.
Your horn panics and shoots an
arrow at it, but he completely
misses.
The creature just scuttles away
in the shadows.
But your horn actually chases
it.
He is so mad at this point he
runs all the way back up to the
rainy roof to find it.
But he loses its trail on the
storm, and when he walks back
down to the bathroom, all the
blood is totally gone.
The tub is completely dry and
dusty.
Pure gaslighting.
Was the blood creature even
real, or is the dark magic of
the castle just actively messing
with his mind now?
It creates this deep, terrifying
doubt in his own senses.
Remember, your horn is the
Ranger.
He's the tracker, the highly
perceptive one in the group.
If he can't even trust his own
eyes anymore, who can they
trust?
Nobody.
And then we finally reached the
climax of the logs.
The wedding cake.
Yes, they wander into this
incredibly dusty abandoned
dining room, and sitting on the
table there is a massive tiered
wedding cake, just slowly
rotting and listing heavily to
one side.
There is a small bride figurine
still standing on top, but the
groom figurine has fallen off,
so Carolyn, investigating the
room, reaches down and picks up
the groom figurine from the
floor.
And the entire cake just
absolutely explodes.
Moldering chunks of ancient cake
and frosting are flying
absolutely everywhere.
Thick dust is swirling all
around the room.
And slowly, in that thick cloud
of dust, the invisible, hulking
silhouette of Strad Vonzarevich
appears.
He is absolutely furious.
He's technically invisible, but
the swirling dust perfectly
outlines his body.
He violently reaches out his and
for peril and.
And that is exactly where the
session log ends.
Talk about an incredible
cliffhanger to end on.
Seriously.
So let's take a breath and just
recap the scoreboard here for a
minute.
This quote UN quote polite
dinner party was an unmitigated
disaster for the heroes.
A total sweeping catastrophe.
Let's list the actual losses
here. 1.
Is Mark is dead.
The Burgo Master, their friend
and guide, is gone forever. 2
Irina is fully confirmed as a
vampire and is now an active
enemy. 3 The Amulet of
Ravenkind, their absolute best
super weapon against the undead,
is securely in enemy hands.
Four, they accidentally set the
roof of the castle on fire, and
five, they willingly gave away
the secret location of their
only allies, the Martikoff
family.
And finally, number six.
They are currently scattered,
physically battered, emotionally
exhausted, and facing a
completely enraged invisible
vampire Lord inside a room full
of exploding wedding cake.
It is a literal master class in
failure, but honestly from a
gameplay perspective is also a
master class in D Ming and
narrative storytelling.
Straw didn't just walk out and
beat them up with high stats.
He cordially invited them
inside, systematically show them
exactly how hopeless their quest
was, carefully peeled away all
their allies, and then just sat
back and let his castle eat them
alive.
Which brings us perfectly back
to the provocative question for
this entire deep dive.
Looking at all this with is Mark
dead on the floor and Irena
fully turned into a monster,
does the party actually have any
valid reason left to stay in
Boruvia?
That is the big question, isn't
it?
Their primary driving mission
for months was Save Irena.
Well, she's a vampire now.
Her brother is dead.
Technically speaking, the
mission is a total failure.
It's game over.
But the real question is, can
they even leave if they want to?
The magical myths still trapped
them in the valley.
They might find themselves
fighting from this point on, not
for any noble heroism or to save
a girl, but purely out of spite
or just raw survival.
And psychologically, when you
strip away a hero's noble 'cause
you're only left with the
survivors desperate, cornered
rage.
And honestly, that might
actually make them far more
dangerous to Straud, because now
they have absolutely nothing
left to lose.
Man, that's a chilling thought.
And what on earth happens when
that invisible wedding cake
ghost finally catches Pearland
in the dusty room?
I guess we're just going to have
to wait for the next batch of
logs to find out.
Indeed we will.
It is going to be a very, very
long night in Castle Ravenloft.
Thank you all so much for
listening to this deep dive.
And hey, if you ever get a fancy
gold lettered dinner invitation
from a reclusive vampire, maybe
just tell them you're busy that
night.
Yeah, just send a polite car.
Welcome.
To the debate.
And I'm joining you to offer a
completely different view.
Today, we are turning our
analytical lens toward the
Valley of Barovia.
Specifically, we are dissecting
the recent and frankly harrowing
expedition undertaken by the
party consisting of Yurihorn,
Radley and Perlin.
Right.
We're looking really closely at
their decision to, well, accept
a dinner invitation from the
dreadlord Strad von Zarevich,
and, of course, the subsequent
navigational nightmare of Castle
Ravenloft itself.
A classic blunder, historically
speaking, walking into the
vampire's lair willingly is.
I mean, it's rarely a survival
positive strategy.
Indeed.
But the central question we are
tackling today really goes to
the very nature of that
environment.
Is Castle Ravenloft primarily a
psychological construct?
You know, a theater designed by
Straud to torment the mind and
soul of his guests.
Or is it, as you often contend,
a highly functional lethal
fortress designed to physically
destroy intruders?
Yeah, it's basically the
difference between a haunted
house attraction and a meat
grinder, and I argue firmly for
the latter.
And I take the position that the
castle is a stage for
psychological warfare.
The physical threats, while
obviously present, are secondary
props.
Straud's primary goal was the
emotional dismantling of his
guests, particularly the
breaking of the burger.
Meister is Mark and the
corruption of his sister Irena.
The castle isn't really designed
to kill the body, it is designed
to shatter the ego.
And I come at it from a very
different angle.
I argue that despite the
undeniable theatricality and
look, Stride is nothing if not
dramatic.
The Castle operates as a lethal
mechanical dungeon.
The environmental hazards, the
traps, the raw combat prowess of
its guardians, those are the
primary vectors of danger.
You see a stage play, I see a
kill box where the party
survived only by honestly
statistical anomaly and high
constitution scores.
Well, let's dive right into the
dinner itself, because I think
this is where the evidence for
psychological warfare is just
incontrovertible.
Consider the setup.
The party arrives.
They meet Raha Deen, They are
ushered into this grand echoing
hall, and Straud is playing the
organ.
It's a bit of a cliche, isn't
it?
It is a deliberate trope.
He is setting a scene.
He isn't rolling initiative.
He is monologuing.
He's talking about his conquest
and his glory.
But the true weapon here wasn't
a sword.
It was the casting of the scene,
the entrance of Irina Koliana.
Which was the entire objective
of is Mark's escort mission.
Exactly.
Is Mark has been utterly
desperate to save his sister.
When she enters, she isn't just
a vampire spawn, she is a total
mockery of the party's entire
crusade.
She's wearing the Amulet of
Ravenkind.
Yeah, that was.
We have to pause on the
significance of that.
This is a holy artifact, a
mechanic explicitly designed to
destroy undead, and she is
wearing it as costume jewelry.
It's a massive flex, I grant
you.
It demonstrates total domination
over the very items that are
supposed to hurt.
Him.
It creates absolute despair.
And she is attended by Yeska,
the former Ultra Boy from Saint
Andrews.
He's not just undead, he's
wearing a frilly rough collar.
He has been reduced to a pet, a
prop on the stage.
It is a.
Deliberate desecration of his
former role as a servant of the
Morning Lord.
Listen, Straw didn't kill is
Mark at that table.
He let is Mark see his sister,
you know, taunting and cruel.
He shattered the man's resolve
before a single hit point was
lost.
That is psychological warfare,
pure and simple.
I see why you prioritize that
interpretation, and I don't deny
the cruelty of the tableau.
It was horrific.
But let me give you a slightly
different perspective.
You're focusing on the cut
scene, but I'm looking at the
resource attrition required to
even reach that cut scene.
Do you mean the approach on the
Spallage Rd.
I mean the ambush before they
even stepped foot in that dining
hall, what happened?
They were nearly annihilated.
This wasn't a mind game.
This was a high CR encounter
designed to drain resources.
Revenants and an ogre zombie
coming out of the tree line.
That is a brute force tactical
strike.
Ismark wasn't psychologically
dismantled there.
He was physically crushed by an
ogre.
He was beaten to within an inch
of his life.
But Ori Horn healed him.
Which cost spell slots.
That's the point.
By the time they walked into
that dining hall, they were
battered.
Their healing pool was totally
depleted, and they knew they
were outmatched.
That ambush set the tone.
It said I can kill you whenever
I want.
If the castle is just a stage,
why soften them up with lethal
force first?
And inside the castle, Just look
at the trap in the secret room
behind the study hearth.
The gas trap.
Right.
Perlin finds a coffer, Yurihorn
opens it, and green gas just
fills the room.
That isn't a Riddle.
It isn't some deep moral
dilemma.
It's a Constitution saving
throw.
Yurihorn and Radley went down
hard.
That gas didn't care about their
feelings or the narrative arc.
It was a blunt force dungeon
trap designed to incapacitate.
I'm really not convinced by that
line of reasoning.
Because the gas didn't kill
them, it incapacitated them.
It heightened the helplessness.
It reinforces the idea that they
are essentially toys to be moved
around the board.
But let's look at the actual
residents they encountered.
Because this, to me, absolutely
proves the theater theory.
Go on.
They find Helga Ruvak, the boot
maker's daughter, in a room that
is clean with unlit lanterns.
She claims to be a maid.
This is a classic damsel setup.
It creates immediate social
friction.
Ismark refuses to leave her.
Radley and Perlin are
suspicious.
Strat has placed her there
specifically to see if the party
will tear itself apart over what
to do with a civilian.
It's a test of character, not
combat prowess.
Or she's a vampire spawn placed
her to ambush them if they let
their guard down, which she is.
Then look at Gertruda.
She's in a lavish bedroom,
completely oblivious.
She tells them she ran away
because the castle looked
majestic.
She thinks Strad is wonderful.
This is designed to confuse the
party's moral compass.
It shows the corrupting power of
Strad's charisma.
It's not a combat encounter.
It's a narrative encounter
designed to make them question
their own definitions of monster
and victim.
And Escher.
The perfect example of Vampire
Consort lounging in a chair
reading a book.
He doesn't attack.
He actually complaints about
being bored.
He's worried Strad will lock him
in a crypt.
He provides lore.
He provides atmosphere.
He emphasizes the and we of
immortality.
If this were a fortress strictly
designed to kill.
Escher rolls initiative the
moment they walk in.
Instead, he chats.
I'm sorry but I just don't buy
that you are seriously cherry
picking the social interactions
and completely ignoring the
initiative roles.
Yes, Escher talks, Helga talks,
but these are merely brief
pauses between intense lethal
violence.
You want to talk about
residents?
Let's talk about the red
animated armor on the
battlements.
The construct that attacked
Perlin.
It didn't just attack, it
executed.
It didn't speak.
It didn't taunt them about their
morals.
It engaged in brutal melee
efficiency.
It used a great sword and
electrical surges.
This wasn't a prop.
It physically slew is Mark.
It beat past his AC, dealt
massive damage, and dropped him.
Then it took down Perlin.
That is the castle functioning
as a fortress.
It identified intruders and
neutralize them with extreme
prejudice.
But that leads to the
resurrection, which is a key
point for me.
Hold on, I'm not done with the
residence.
What about the thing in the
bathtub?
Your horn walks into a dark
bathroom and a screaming figure
made of blood launches itself
out of the tub.
The Blood Simulacrum.
It was a predator.
It's scuttles on the ceiling.
It drips blood.
Yuri Horn is firing arrows at it
in a panic.
This isn't a conversation about
N We.
It's a desperate fight for
survival against a monster.
Even the giant spiders in the
belfry.
Those are classic physical
threats requiring fire and steel
to overcome.
The residents of Ravenlofter
monsters.
The fact that some of them talk
before they bite doesn't change
their stat blocks.
That's a fairpoint, though.
I would frame the quote UN quote
death of is Mark very
differently, which we will get
to.
But first we really have to
discuss the architecture itself.
You claim it's a military
fortress.
I look at the layout and I see a
fun house.
A fun house that implies it's
harmless.
No, it implies it is deeply
disorienting.
Look at the audience hall.
The throne faces the wall.
Why?
It serves literally no
functional purpose for a ruler.
Mechanically, it creates a
massive blind spot, but
artistically it is a profound
statement of contempt for his
courtiers.
It is art.
Or consider the mannequin the
prank.
It is explicitly a prank.
They are walking down a dark
hall.
They hear a terrifying moan.
A fanged visage flies at them
and it's a doll on ropes and
pulleys.
The moan is just wind blowing
through holes.
This proves beyond the shadow of
a doubt that Straud has set this
up as a haunted house
attraction.
He is mocking their fear.
A fortress doesn't have jump
scare mannequins.
A stage set does.
I see the mannequin as the
exception, not the rule.
It lures you into a false sense
of security right before you
step into a lethal hazard.
Because if you look at the macro
level architecture, it is pure
military fortification.
We are talking about 100 foot
drop from the parapets.
We are talking about a
drawbridge over a gorge that
violently sways in the wind.
These are defensive structures
designed to limit movement and
create fatal fall damage
opportunities.
Standard castle designs, surely?
But look at the interior
mechanics, the secret doors.
Perlin had to perform a
laborious search, a highly
difficult skill check, just to
find that Wayne's coded passage.
And the mechanics to open the
secret door in the hearth.
They had to manipulate the fire
poker.
To open the next one, they had
to put a torch back in a
specific sconce.
This is a complex mechanical
puzzle dungeon.
It requires physical interaction
with the environment to
progress.
Which feeds perfectly into the
game aspect.
Straud is the game master.
It feeds into the lethality.
Look at the fire in the belfry.
Yurihorn lights the webs to kill
the spiders.
What happens?
The dry Timbers ignite.
The roof catches fire.
The physics of the world are
real.
The castle burns like a real
structure.
It isn't some illusion that
dissipates when you disbelieve
it.
If you stay in that fire, you
take fire damage.
If you fall off that bridge, you
take fall damage.
Roughly 10D6 worth of it.
The architecture is a weapon.
And yet we must address the
corpse, or rather the lack
thereof.
In the room you mentioned is
Mark was slain by the armor,
Perlin was struck down and yet
they woke up.
They did.
They woke up in a nice veg
chamber with Escher.
If Ravenloft is a fortress
designed to destroy intruders,
why are they still breathing?
Why did the armor stop its
assault once they were
unconscious?
Why were they stabilized and
moved to a guest room?
This is the ultimate proof of
the stage theory.
Straud is playing with his food.
He killed IS Mark or removed him
because is Mark was the
emotional anchor.
Once is Mark was broken and
defeated, the scene was over.
That is a very compelling
narrative argument, but I think
you are fundamentally
misinterpreting the mechanics of
Borovia and the true nature of
the curse.
How so?
Is Mark is gone?
You say removed, I say dead.
The blood was cleaned up, sure,
but the notes specifically
mentioned the stain remained on
the floor.
The lethality was entirely real
for the NPC.
The party surviving.
That might not be Straud's
mercy.
That might be the specific curse
of the Demi Plain.
Remember the revenants?
They said, we shall meet again.
Death is not an escape in
Borovia.
So you think the castle actually
killed them and the land itself
brought them back?
Or the Dark Powers did.
Or perhaps Straud simply
stabilized them so we could
torture them further.
Yes, but the violence of the act
was real.
The armor didn't pull its
punches.
It dealt lethal damage.
The outcome survival doesn't
negate the intent of the attack,
which was to destroy.
I disagree if I shoot you with a
gun but have a team of doctors
on standby to save you, I am not
trying to kill you, I am trying
to traumatize you.
Just look at the wedding cake
incident at the end.
The dining room finale?
Yes, Berlin picks up the bride
figurine and the cake just
explodes, moldering chunks
everywhere.
And then an invisible raging
straw starts destroying the
room.
You might call that theatrics,
but look at the nature of it.
It's a temper tantrum.
It's described as the invisible
silhouette of an enraged straw.
It's highly emotional.
It's a metaphor for his decayed
marriage prospects and his
eternal obsession.
It's not a strategic military
strike.
It's a scene from a tragic
opera.
See, I look at the exact same
event and draw a completely
different conclusion.
You see a metaphor, I see a
proximity mine.
Perlin disturbed a specific
object, the figurine, and it
triggered an explosive hazard.
The cake, the invisible straw
throwing furniture, that is a
poltergeist effect or a
telekinesis spell.
Its physical force, it shattered
glass, it created difficult
terrain.
It creates a highly hazardous
environment where movement is
penalized.
But the portrait in the study
they find a centuries old
painting of is Mark's sister
Arena that is pure gas lighting.
It's designed to completely
destabilize is Mark's
understanding of reality and
time.
The castle attacks their sanity
first and their bodies second.
Again, I see the portrait as a
conveyance of lore.
It's a hard fact of their
reality that the soul is
recycled.
It's an exposition dump, not a
weapon.
But let's go back to the very
start of the encounter.
Rahed N.
The Chamberlain.
The screaming voices when he
gets close.
You would call that a psychic
attack.
Absolutely.
It relies entirely on the horror
of hearing the voices of the
dead.
It demands an emotional
response.
It demands a Constitution saving
throw for psychic damage.
It's an aura.
It's a weaponized defensive
capability.
It's not just spooky noises to
make you sad.
It's a hazard that causes
tangible physical pain and
incapacitation.
Raheden isn't just an actor in a
Butler suit.
He's a walking area of effect
spell.
We certainly view the mechanics
differently, but let's look at
where they ended up.
They are running Yuri Horn is
chasing a blood vampire that
vanishes, magically I might add,
totally supporting the illusion
theory.
And then they are fleeing an
invisible, raging entity.
They're confused, terrified, and
separated.
The stagecraft has worked
perfectly.
And they are also battered,
bruised, completely out of spell
slots and -1 Burgermeister.
The fortress has taken its toll.
So as we wrap up, I stand firm.
By my assessment, Ravenloft is a
projection of Strawd's psyche.
From the polite dinner to the
prank mannequin, from the
centuries old portrait to the
vanishing blood in the bathtub,
the absolute goal was to drive
is Mark to despair and the party
to confusion.
The physical traps, the gas, the
armor, they are just props.
The dangerous props, sure, like
a loaded gun on a stage, but
props nonetheless.
The real damage was done to is
Mark's heart when he saw Irena
in that chair.
And I maintain that the
psychological elements are just
a thin veneer over a meat
grinder.
The gas was lethal, the spiders
were lethal, the electrical
shocks from the armor were
highly lethal.
Is Mark is dead because he was
hit with a great sword, not
because his feelings were hurt.
The party survived by pure luck,
a high tolerance for pain, and
perhaps the perverse rules of
the Demi plane.
But make no mistake, the castle
actively tried to kill them.
Perhaps the true horror of
Ravenloft is the synergy of
both.
I can certainly agree with that.
It disarms you with absurdity.
A wedding cake.
A silly mannequin right before
it hits you with harsh reality.
You're laughing at the puppet
and then the floor drops out.
Exactly.
It uses the confusion to lower
your armor class so the blade
strikes true.
A terrifying thought, and
certainly a lesson for anyone
thinking of accepting a dinner
invitation from a vampire Lord.
Indeed, bring a sword, bring a
cleric, and maybe just don't eat
the cake.
Thank you for joining us for the
debate.
We really encourage you to look
at your own games, your own
stories.
Where exactly is the line
between a performance and a
genuine threat?
And is the difference really
just a matter of hit points?
Today we are dissecting a three
session cursive strad narrative
arc covering the dinner with
strad arena's vampire revelation
is Mark's death and a chaotic.
Castle exploration Major
protagonist deaths require
narrative framing that matches
their emotional and plot
significance to maximize impact.
Yeah, exactly.
And that brings us right into
our first piece of feedback,
right?
Looking at Session 20, 29, we've
got the death of Ismark the
Burgomaster, and he's not just
some random MPC.
No, he's the driver of the plot.
He brought them to Ravenloft.
Exactly.
But the weakness here is that
his death feels like a purely
mechanical casualty.
It really does.
It happens incredibly abruptly
during this combat encounter
with an animated armor.
Yeah, the text just says the
armor beats past his guard and
electrical surges finish him
off.
Right, it reads like a
transaction in a Ledger.
Hit points reduced to 0.
Status dead.
Yes, it completely lacks the
tragic climax that a character
of this magnitude deserves.
You know it focuses on the
mechanics of the hit rather than
the weight of the loss.
Which is a shame, because just
moments before this, Ismark was
weeping over that centuries old
portrait of his sister.
He realized he failed her.
Right.
That's such a heavy emotional
beat, and to go from that
straight into a sterile,
functional description of
combat, it just misses the mark.
So the suggestion here is to
deliberately slow down the
narrative pacing during the
death scene.
Yeah.
You need to focus on the
emotional resonance rather than
the physical action of the
armor.
Shift the lens from the what to
the how it feels.
Exactly, and justice to give a
few concrete examples of how you
might execute this.
And these are just a couple of
options out of many.
Instead of describing the
armor's efficiency, describe his
marks.
Final view.
Oh, I like that.
Limit the description of
physical pain.
Describe his eyes staring past
the armor, maybe looking back at
that window toward the portrait.
Internalize the moment.
Right.
His eyes glaze over with this
heartbreaking acceptance that he
failed.
Yeah, another concrete example
could be contrasting the hollow
nature of the armor with
Ismarc's emotional burden.
Oh, that's brilliant.
Right.
He's being killed by an empty
shell.
No soul, no feeling.
It emphasizes the irony that
after facing the emotive horror
of his vampire sister, he gets
undone by a soulless object.
Yes, it turns a standard combat
round into a thematic statement.
Definitely.
Maintaining the suspension of
disbelief in a horror setting
relies on minimizing elements
that break the established mood
of sophisticated dread.
And that leads perfectly into
the environment of the study
itself.
Yes, the fire incident.
Right, the author is clearly
aiming for high stakes.
Gothic whore.
We've got the screaming aura,
Irina wearing the amulet.
Psychological torture.
It's very Bram Stoker.
But then, to extinguish a fire
in the study, the players decide
to urinate on the embers.
Yeah.
The weakness here is a massive,
jarring tonal clash.
It really is.
It pulls the narrative straight
out of a tragedy and right into
a frat house comedy.
It undermines all that tension
built up in the chambers of
weeping.
Exactly.
The players are always going to
do chaotic things right, but the
weakness is that the narrative
just lets it happen without
consequence, which condones that
tonal shift.
So the suggestion isn't to take
away player agency and just say
no.
No ever break agency.
Right.
The suggestion is to describe
the environment reacting
negatively to that crude
behavior, filter their actions
through a narrative lens that
maintains the grim atmosphere.
Yes, for example.
And again, these are just a few
concrete ways to handle it.
If they do this, don't play it
for laughs, right?
Describe the smoke reacting.
It shouldn't just disappear, it
should choke the room.
Give them this desperate, smoky
suffocation.
Like the room itself is
disgusted by them.
Exactly, you could have the
smoke form a judging visage.
Oh.
Maybe the face of the portrait
they just desecrate.
Yes, or make the smell
unnaturally foul.
A supernatural stench.
Right, a concrete mechanical
example.
That stench of disrespect clings
to their clothes and it gives
them disadvantage on their next
social check with Straud.
That's perfect.
It punishes the characters for
treating the setting trivially.
It reasserts the genre.
Yeah, it tells them you can act
like clowns, but this castle
will treat you like vermin.
Transitions that rescue
characters from certain death
must be framed as intentional
villainous agency rather than
obvious plot armor.
Yes, this is crucial for the
aftermath on the battlements.
Right, because is Mark dies,
Pearland is struck down, and
then they just fade to black and
wake up in a guest room with
Escher.
The weakness here is that it
feels like a total Deus Ex
machina to avoid a party wipe.
It disconnects the cause and
effect.
Completely.
It lowers the stakes because the
players suddenly feel like they
can't actually lose.
The DL will just wake them up
somewhere safe.
So the suggestion is to
explicitly frame their survival
as a calculated act of cruelty
or boredom by Straud.
Not just a lucky black blackout.
Exactly.
It needs to feel imposed.
Right, so looking at concrete
examples when they wake up with
Escher, don't just have him
sitting there reading a book.
Have him explicitly comment on
it.
Yes, so he could say something
like the master isn't finished
playing with you yet.
Or death is a gift you haven't
earned.
Oh, that's chilling.
I love that.
It turns their survival into a
sentence.
Exactly.
Another concrete example to fix
this is describing the physical
lingering of effects of that
near death experience.
Right, they shouldn't just wake
up with full hit points feeling
fine.
Give them deep aching scars
where the armors struck them, or
a supernatural chill.
Maybe they're missing an
important item that Straud took
as a trophy.
Yes, ensure that the defeat
carries A lasting penalty.
They need to know they lost the
fight, even if they survived.
That brings us to the aftermath
when they start roaming the
castle.
Right, the transition from high
tension social encounters to
dungeon crawling needs to
sustain the psychological
pressure established in the
opening scene.
And the weakness identified here
is that the narrative tension
dips significantly after the
dinner.
It really does.
You have this massive emotional
peek with vampire Irina.
Yeah.
But then it's immediately
followed by aimless exploration.
They find empty rooms, a dummy
mannequin prank, and leaf the
accountant.
The horror becomes totally
procedural.
Exactly.
Checking doors, looking for
loot.
The psychological dread
vanishes.
So the suggestion is to infuse
the exploration phase with
echoes of the Dinners
revelation.
Make the castle feel like an
extension of Stroud's mockery.
Right.
Don't let the tension release.
Change the type of tension.
For example, instead of a
generic Scooby-doo mannequin
prank.
Right, a dummy that just groans.
Have the mannequin dressed to
resemble their lost cleric.
Or the recently deceased is
Mark.
Yes, when they realize it's a
fake, it's not a relief, it's a
psychological taunt.
It shows Stroud is watching and
mocking their grief.
These are great examples of
keeping that pressure.
Up And what about leaf lip
siege?
Right, the accountant.
A concrete example of fixing
that encounter is linking his
accounting directly to the
party's actions.
Instead of him just doing
generic taxes exactly have him
tallying the cost of the dinner
to the state or calculating the
value of a arena as a bride
versus a hostage.
That forces them to re engage
with the plot even during a
mundane social encounter.
It makes Leaf a reminder of the
bureaucracy of evil, not just an
obstacle.
Interactive objects in the
environment should serve to
deepen the lore or foreshadow
immediate threats, rather than
just acting as physics puzzles.
Yes, the environmental
storytelling.
We have two major set pieces
here, the wedding cake with the
bride figurine and the bathtub
full of blood.
Great gothic imagery.
Incredible imagery.
The author's intent is clear, to
lean into that classic
aesthetic, right?
But the weakness is that their
triggers feel totally
disconnected.
The cake explodes because a
figurine was touched.
And a vampire jumps out of the
tub when they look at it.
Yeah, they feel like gotcha
traps.
Exactly, they read like video
game physics puzzles touch XY
explodes.
They aren't integrated story
moments.
So the suggestion is to tie
those environmental traps
directly to the narrative of the
wedding or the tragedy of the
inhabitants.
Make them symbolic, right?
So for concrete examples, the
cake shouldn't just be a
proximity mine made of flower.
Right when they remove the bride
figurine.
It should rot rapidly, molding
and collapsing in seconds.
Or perhaps it begins to bleed.
Symbolizing the corruption of
the wedding and Arena's fate.
Yes, the cost should feel
supernatural and symbolic, not
mechanical.
And for the bathtub?
Instead of just springing a
combat encounter which is a jump
scare, build suspense.
Let them see the forest before.
Or the tree.
Exactly.
A concrete way to do this is to
allow the players to hear
weeping coming from the tub
before the attack.
Or see ripples in the liquid.
Give the moment to dread what's
about to happen.
That's always scarier than the
monster itself.
And if the spawn in the tub is
wearing a tattered wedding
dress, it links back to Straud's
bride.
Exactly.
It becomes a lower point, not
just a stat block.
Well, this has been a really
thorough look at this session
art.
It has to recap briefly for the
listener.
We've got 4 actionable areas.
Right.
First, give true narrative
weight to major deaths like
Izmarks by slowing down and
focusing on the emotional
realization of failure rather
than the combat mechanics. 2nd,
eliminate those tonal
inconsistencies.
If the players act like frat
boys in a horror castle, the
environment needs to punish them
to maintain the dread. 3rd frame
any survival from a party wipe
as Straud's intentional cruelty
make them feel the cost of
losing.
And finally, sustain that
psychological pressure during
exploration by tying mundane
objects and traps like the
mannequin, the accountant, and
the cake directly into the
trauma of the overarching
narrative.
Exactly.
These adjustments will align the
mechanics with the incredibly
high mistakes of this campaign.
We strongly invite the listener
to submit their next set of
session logs to the critique so
we can see how The Escape from
Ravenloft ultimately concludes.
Can't wait to read it.
Thanks for tuning in.